[Musica]
buonasera buonasera a tutti sono sono
molto emozionata lo so ve l'hanno
praticamente detto tutti oggi ma sono
emozionata per la duplice responsabilità
che ho un po sulle spalle chiudo questi
speech del primo the next sapienza e poi
insieme alle colleghe che avete sentito
oggi rappresenta un po la mia
generazione no la nostra generazione la
generazione z lo so lo so siamo un po
quel giano bifronte contemporaneamente
rivolto agli anni 80 e futurama siamo
quella zona grigia nella storia
contemporanea fatta di pensiero positivo
battaglie per l'inclusività e stress
post traumatico congenito
non siamo anche una generazione
appassionata
frizzante
pittoresca
certo chiamata solo ad affrontare le
sfide più ardue mai vissuto dall uomo ea
livello globale ma insomma siamo la
fortuna dei terapisti
da classicista poi e quindi più
interessata ad antichità perdute che a
quello che ho effettivamente sotto il
naso
godo di un'inquietante vantaggio vi
spiego
immaginate casa vostra
la casa della vostra infanzia nel
quartiere in cui siete cresciuti
e pensate che accanto vi sia una collina
abbastanza alta dalla quale potete
vedere è lo stesso luogo ma da lontano
da
una prospettiva che vi esclude dal
contesto vi sembrerà di essere
contemporaneamente
dentro e fuori
ecco così e come mi sento io
qual è il vantaggio beh allora il
vantaggio ovviamente e l'oggettività
dello sguardo esterno un privilegio che
mi ha permesso di capire che tutto
questo grande fermento generazionale
conosce ancora una pericolosa zona opaca
ma ci torneremo tra poco
intanto per i prossimi dieci minuti
facciamo un patto po come a teatro
dimenticate chi sono e lasciate che vi
parli di una cosa veramente molto
importante per me perché oggi sono qui
con voi per parlarvi di progresso
scientifico
un po come dice la mia presentazione
ecco vi ho portato un testo per
l'occasione ora non spaventatevi andò a
non solo a leggerlo ma anche a tradurlo
per voi
allora utoya parquet spanta freud nei
toni ci pensa al crozet un test e fiori
scusi sa mai non
traduzione ma gli dei non hanno dato ai
mortali fin dal principio ogni cosa non
gliel'hanno rivelata ma con il tempo e
si ricercando trovano di volta in volta
il meglio ecco questo è il frammento 18
nell'edizione di crans di senofane di
call of one è un poeta greco del sesto
secolo avanti cristo e questa è la prima
definizione della moderna idea di
progresso
occidentale ho evidenziato alcune parole
per l'occasione e andremo a leggerle
commentarle insieme la prima juppé dei
xan ora è una ho visto che
come molti di voi sapranno è l'incubo di
tutti gli studenti del liceo classico ma
è un tempo verbale che indica una azione
che è iniziata e terminata in un passato
ben preciso si tratta di un verbo un po
della rivelazione vuol dire io mostro io
rivelo io espongo
senofane qui ci sta dicendo che
non crede più al mito di prometeo quindi
a quel fuoco della conoscenza infuso è
un'epoca ancestrale no ci dice che gli
dei non ci hanno rivelato tutto
dall'inizio ma avversativa e questo ci
porta alla seconda parola crono con il
tempo è un dativo e ci dà il senso della
durata di una azione quali sono queste
azioni la prima è espressa da questo
bellissimo participio presente che viene
da zero e vuol dire io ricerco cerco ha
una forte valenza fisica un po come
quando voi
perdete il telecomando nei meandri del
divano e stand di
serie a cercarlo con la ma non ho sete o
ha proprio questo questo senso e quindi
sono quegli uomini che cercano cercano
ricercano questa sfumatura iterativa ce
l'abbiamo non solo dalla uso del
presente ma anche da dato temporale che
abbiamo visto prima crono e proprio
perché ricercano trovano e fiori scusi
usa un'altra volta il presente perché
senofane non vuole essere profetico non
ci dice che sicuramente gli uomini
troveranno qualcosa ci dice che
chi cerca prima o poi qualcosa prova
ecco in questi due versi
senofane che
lontanissimo da noi per cultura epoca
storica area geografica
la persona più lontana da noi tra tutte
riesce a comunicare efficacemente la
nostra idea di progresso
e comunicare non è semplice no anzi è
un'azione che noi spesso confondiamo con
un'altra azione che è di fornire delle
informazioni
senofane non ci sta dando delle
informazioni o dei dati precisi ma vi
assicuro che il suo pubblico aveva
perfettamente compreso e soprattutto
condiviso il suo pensiero
perché senofane non è un pensatore
originale questo un errore che spesso
facciamo con i classici pensiamo che
tutti i grandi poeti siano pensatori
originali ma no non esiste l'originalità
nella grecia antica sede versi del
genere sono sopravvissuti fino a noi
vuol dire che erano assolutamente
condivisi
è questo il bello della comunicazione
efficace il fatto di oltrepassare il
tempo e lo spazio
ma come fa una comunicazione essere
efficace ho evidenziato un ultima parola
questa è a me non è un aggettivo al
grado comparativo l'abbiamo tradotta
come il meglio
ora senofane sicuramente conoscevo mero
e quindi ha fatto una scelta ben precisa
non ha detto ariston
bello
altisonante poetico omerico la cosa
migliore tra tutte no no no no perché
senofane non è un illuminista come non
pensa che di dei abbiano rivelato tutto
subito in un epoca ancestrale non pensa
nemmeno che gli uomini possano fare
miracoli
ma attenzione perché qua arriva il bello
in tutti i sensi perché il grado zero di
questo aggettivo è a garros
e non so chi di voi abbia fatto questa
esperienza mistica del liceo classico
chiunque di voi abbia fatto liceo
classico si ricorderà sicuramente questa
espressione kalòs kai agathos
bello e buono
un po come achille
achille è bello e buono ma se per bello
possiamo pensare a brad pitt in troy per
buono dobbiamo fare uno sforzo in più
buono è tutto il complesso di valori
condivisi all'interno di una comunità
in greco una forte valenza etica
dunque il progresso di senofane è una
continua ricerca di ciò che di volta in
volta è considerato il meglio per una
comunità e il risultato non può che
essere positivo perché l'uomo che
ricerca pur sbagliando sbaglia credendo
di fare il bene della comunità perché
per la comunità ha una forte
responsabilità
e voi mi direte vabbè ma se non fanno un
poeta che ne sa lui il progresso di
quello che è bene per la comunità eh eh
no perché senofane non è solo un poeta
se non fa né un poeta è un filosofo
in un periodo in cui la filosofia e
scienza
si anche lei che non ci crede e scienza
ma non solo senofane poeta filosofo e
scienziato in una cultura in cui questi
non sono mestieri senofane aveva un
altro mestiere è un uomo colto quindi
possiamo immaginare che lui
nella opulenta quello fuori del sesto
secolo fosse un ricco proprietario
terriero quindi un cittadino e dunque
ricopriva tutti i suoi doveri gli oneri
politici civili partecipando attivamente
alle guerre che erano tantissime in
grecia ea partecipando attivamente ai
processi in tribunale quindi per lui è
naturale che il progresso non possa
essere individuale non possa essere
giunto all'interno di una biblioteca o
di un di un laboratorio
perché la responsabilità della ricerca
accade sull'uomo anzi sugli uomini jet
un test e figuris così sono tutti
plurali
ovviamente questa non è farina del mio
sacco anch'io commissionò fan e non sono
un pensatore originale ma sono stata
ispirata da quest'uomo
questa foto è bellissima e anche lo
sfondo del mio desktop del computer
lui è hans von hans e nel suo saggio sul
principio di responsabilità della
scienza scrive che l'uomo soprattutto
nella storia contemporanea ha
imparato a controllare la natura al suo
piacimento
però spesso ci dimentichiamo del fattore
etico
e sì perché
l'etica secondo ion hans a due fattori
uno positivo che anche oggettivo e uno
soggettivo
uno risponde alla ragione l'altro al
sentimento ed entrambi sono
assolutamente complementari perché
se il richiamo al dovere esclude la
sfera del sentimento
l'uomo non ha più alcuna forza motivante
che modelli e indirizzi il suo agire e
quindi uno scienziato secondo yonas
rischia di diventare un prometeo
scatenato perché perché non ha più
interlocutori etici
anzi
al giorno d'oggi
non ne ha affatto
no
lo abbiamo visto
durante la pandemia
molti scienziati studiosi sono stati
chiamati a uscire dalla loro confort son
di laboratorio per comunicare un
pubblico profano
quello che stava semplicemente accadendo
un disastro
le conseguenze di tanti talk show e
interviste sono state panico e ignoranza
perché
ma perché il progresso né più a diretto
contatto con la comunità perché ma
perché è soltanto quella empatia quella
particolare condivisione di valori
positivi e soggettivi a rendere una
comunicazione efficace come i versi di
senofane ea rendere ogni ambito del
sapere
attivamente partecipe
noi
tutti siamo convinti che
l'iperspecializzazione sia la chiave del
successo accademico sì lo è
indubbiamente individualmente ma
a che prezzo
voglio chiudere con una nota di
positività
beh lui dai lui non ha bisogno di
presentazioni e telmo pievani è un
habitué del ted è un filosofo
evoluzionista e
all'università di padova fa una cosa fa
una cosa bellissima lui ricopre la prima
cattedra in italia di filosofia delle
scienze biologiche per il dipartimento
di biologia cioè questa è la vanguardia
pure la bellezza del xxi secolo anche se
telmo come vedete non è proprio un
grande rappresentante della generazione
z è un po più agée ma
come vi dicevo all'inizio la generazione
z in questo ambito la generazione z che
attenzione e tour molto prodiga
ed è molto aperta
l'inclusività alla contaminazione
nell'ambito accademico conosce ancora
diversi tabù se si può dire
me ne sono accorta un convegno era il
mio primo convegno e mi ero appena
laureata insomma e
ci andai a un po come si va al primo
appuntamento no con una persona che ci
piace tanto
e
questa cosa mi emoziona particolarmente
perché in sala c'è qualcuno che mi da
questo questi film e quindi un po come
si fa al primo appuntamento
mi ero preparato un bel discorsetto
davanti davanti allo specchio stile
truman show per rispondere un po
brillantemente alle domande di rito mini
chi sei da dove vieni erano tutte
emozionata a rivoli e ben vestito e
vengo accolta da questo
essere mitologico spartiacque
noi per brevità lo chiameremo minosse
lei
si occupa
io non sapevo come rispondere a questa
domanda me l'ho preparata 3000 discorsi
ma questa proprio ma poi di che si
occupa che significa mi ero appena
laureata con una tesi compilativa ero in
preda al panico
cerco di
dissimulare edicola prima cosa che mi
viene in mente
filologia classica
si accomodi con altri filologi
ovviamente non c'era una precisa
disposizione non
ognuno poteva sedersi dove voleva ma il
nostro simpatico minosse aveva dato un
po per scontato che
avrei avuto maggiore affinità con altri
filologi anzi probabilmente una
studentessa barbatella un po snob molto
irrigidita è vestita di tutto punto come
me
non poteva fare altro che parlare con i
filologi
ma capite lo ha dato per scontato non è
una leggera proprio una radicata e
profonda
disposizione culturale una convinzione
eppure
minosse
era della generazione zero
grazie
[Applauso]